on est très ménagé en ce moment
calme-toi non non mais arrête mais si
toi là si franchement de toute façon je
vais vous dire ça changera rien tout va
bien c'est pas ce que je vais te dire
que je suis pas inquiet ou pas inquiet
tous les hommes à partir de 50 ans
doivent le faire bien sûr
les examens comme ça ce soir celle-ci
regardez-les à côté de l'autre on dirait
un piano
[Rires]
mais par contre ça sera jamais un piège
dans la cuisine
va pas aimer du tout et voyez
qu'elle se
passe Delphine vous avez vu elle a voulu
non mais je l'adore et je l'embrasse et
je lui souhaite le meilleur voilà je
l'adore je connais vous savez dernière
personne qui a dit j'adore Delphine elle
a poussé dans les escaliers
c'est bon les gars aussi alors je vais
vous dire dans ce métier des cacas alors
je vous dis dès que quelqu'un vous dit
je l'adore
moi quand je vais découper quelqu'un je
démarre toujours ma phrase par je
l'adore après il sait qu'il va en
prendre plein la gueule donc on va pas
se mentir non mais dans ce métier
d'ailleurs j'ai envie qu'on fasse un jeu
vous allez dire je l'adore et après vous
allez découper quelqu'un autour de la
table
tu veux tu veux démarrer oui
j'adore Gilles Verdez mais je pourrais
lui pisser dans la gueule
[Applaudissements]
dans les débats tu me rassure
l'homme à la répartie légendaire il y a
un homme que j'adore mais c'est vous ah
vas-y ma valise la vérité tu veux que je
dis la vérité
[Rires]
tu es un gros connard
et on a mis ton chien là
on a un maître chien
il y a pas de porte là-bas mais c'est
pas demandé de sortir
[Rires]
c'est pas possible